so when you're looking at your phone in
video mode reverse back on you as a
mirror which I think have you done that
I always get embarrassed to like get a
mirror out and like have people see me
in the mirror and so when you're on your
phone you can kind of hide it and figure
like oh I'm just looking at my Instagram
but actually you're looking at yourself
and going am I okay right well get ready
for this so I found an app it's just
called Mirror it's free you open it up
unlike the iPhone with the video the
mirror
again serious yes oh my gosh my makeup
looks so good Drew right one thing I was
going to say about commuting is a good
idea to get a long wear lipstick that
you don't have to touch up that would be
this give Beauty right here so that is
long wear it's long wear and it's just
so comfortable and it will smell it and
see if you like that smell
oh gosh it smells like vanilla it smells
like yum like like cupcakes yes frosting